new show where we track the changes
happening to our world right now and
challenge those coming up with the
solutions
now there are different interpretations
this evening about why key climate
targets were dropped from the uk
australia trade deal according to the
government here environmental safeguards
remain and the text implicitly commits
australia to measures from the landmark
paris agreement including limiting
global warming to 1.5 degrees and here
on the data dashboard you can see that
we're currently at over 1.2 degrees of
warming
but today the australian prime minister
said it was a trade agreement not a
climate one our deputy political editor
sam coats reports
a warm welcome to the australian prime
minister because this summer he opened
the door to something boris johnson
wants fast a uk australia trade deal
but out of the glare of the cameras came
a british climb down sky news revealed
yesterday that just weeks after these
two prime ministers met elite uk cabinet
office email we obtained said that the
business secretary has agreed that in
order to get the australia fta free
trade agreement over the line the dit
department for international trade can
drop both of the climate asks including
a reference to the paris agreement
temperature goals
the business secretary at a new
statesman event tonight asked to respond
conceding temperature goals were dropped
but insisting this won't make any
difference i didn't recognize that issue
that somehow we'd removed the paris
agreement
language there may have been an issue
about
specifically putting 1.50 uh 1.5 degrees
on the face of the negotiating mandate
uh but there was absolutely explicit
reference in the paris agreement uh in
the in the negotiating mandate
but despite attempts to play it down it
still caused huge controversy down under
the federal government is being accused
of watering down environmental
protections a leaked email from a senior
official in the british cabinet office
obtained by sky news uk shows that in
order to get the australia uk free trade
deal through the brits dropped
requirements under the paris agreement
the australian prime minister this
morning confirming the story but
insisting he isn't abandoning the
climate we're not going to talk it we're
going to do it and we're going to keep
doing it but confirming the sky news
story making it clear why he opposes
climate targets in trade agreements
it wasn't a climate agreement it was a
trade agreement
and i do trade agreements and in trade
agreements i deal with trade issues in
climate agreements i deal with climate
issues
so the australian prime minister says
that the uk trade deal is nothing to do
with climate change the uk government
says that there are plenty of
commitments about climate change in the
australia trade deal they can't both be
right what's really happening though
depends on the detail
as with any trade deal comes complicated
language in the email we saw the dit
that's the department of trade also say
they could drop climate asks concerning
the precedence of multilateral
environmental agreements over fta
provisions in short that means allowing
the australians to ignore other climate
agreements without losing the benefits
of this deal
but it's so unclear what that means so
today the chair of the business select
committee has written to the secretary
of state for international trade
demanding they list the multilateral
environmental agreements that were
de-prioritized over the provisions in
the free trade agreement
i'm going to ask ministers to list
deal by deal rule by rule
which climate agreements they've now
decided to disregard in order to get
this trade deal over the line it could
be bigger than dropping just paris
agreement targets but also symbolically
that's fundamentally a problem as we get
so close to cop 26 in november with just
50 days to go time is running out time
is running out to avoid the most severe
effects of climate change and it's
running out fast with the minister for
the climate conference cop 26 traveling
the world to emphasize urgency the time
for talking is behind us
what we need now is action
action to drive down global emissions
action should protect people and nature
from the effects of climate change
actions not words matter especially as
everyone prepares to turn to britain to
show climate leadership
sam coates sky news
in today's other climate news sir david
attenborough has urged politicians to do
more to help people cut their emissions
in order for the uk to reach its climate
targets by 2050. speaking one year on
from the publication of the first
uk-wide citizens assembly on climate
change report the naturalist and
broadcaster said the public need to be
given confidence that the changes needed
to cut emissions are desirable and
possible
some of the world's most climate
vulnerable countries have said
november's cop 26 summit must not be
delayed the chairman of the alliance of
small island states said climate change
is not pausing and urgent action is
critical to giving developing small
island states a chance of survival the
intervention comes after calls for the
meeting to be postponed due to failures
in the global vaccine rollout and fears
that quarantine could exclude some
countries from the talks
it's world ev or electric vehicle day
and to mark the occasion the
government's launched a new free app ev8
switch is designed to encourage hesitant
petrol and diesel car owners to make the
switch to electric by calculating how
much money and co2 they could save the
government has also committed to
additional support for small businesses
and renters to install ev charging
points
and we're going to be discussing
electric cars and whether they really
are as green as they seem in our daily
climate show debate and today i'm joined
by the economist vicky price and climate
columnist at the independent donor
mccarthy that's coming up in a few
minutes time
now all companies will need to plan for
major drops in production in the next 10
years if climate targets are to be met
that's the warning in a new report from
the financial think tank carbon tracker
which says the companies such as shell
and bp would need to cut production by
at least a third to keep global warming
below 1.5 degrees
despite shell and bp releasing plans to
reach net zero emissions by 2050 the
report warns that oil and gas companies
are still betting against the success of
global efforts to tackle climate change
well that warning comes as the world's
largest machine that captures carbon
from the air has started operating in
iceland the orca plant will remove 4 000
tons of carbon dioxide from the air
every year which may sound like a lot
but it's actually only a tiny percentage
of greenhouse gas emissions
well in a moment i'll be speaking to a
carbon capture expert about whether the
technology could offer a realistic way
to slow global warming but first here's
more about it
[Music]
so co2 that was in the environment
yesterday is in this pipe today
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
co2 still has to fill up the holes and
then this is what it looks like after
dr mai bowie from the center for
environmental policy at imperial college
london is an expert in carbon capture
and joins me now so welcome to you so a
giant machine that sucks carbon dioxide
out of the air is this the big solution
to climate change that we need
uh yes it's going to be one of a
combination of different technologies
within our portfolio uh direct air
capture isn't the sort of silver bullet
it's going to be capturing the the co2
that's released as sort of residual
ambitions from power plants and hard to
abate sectors so things like
agricultural greenhouse gas emissions
can't actually be captured so you need
technologies that remove co2 from air
like direct air capture to kind of
offset those emissions so it is going to
be one of the key sort of technologies
in addition to other co2 removal
technologies like afforestation or
bioenergy with ccs
well yes and this machine may be huge
but it only captures a tiny fraction of
the carbon dioxide that we need to take
out as the atmosphere we're going to get
to net zero
how could it be rolled out at scale and
would that be very expensive
yeah so this is really kind of the first
of a kind uh sort of demonstration of
direct air capture showing its
feasibility so now we kind of know that
it's work it does work we can now start
to think about ramping up and scaling up
the production of these types of units
to try to distribute them around
different parts of the world and so it
is a large-scale problem in that we've
got a lot of units to build in order to
kind of meet these climate change
targets that we've set for ourselves
which are quite ambitious
and and it's costly
uh yes so as you know as the report kind
of shows uh the concentration of co2
within air is quite low concentrated so
you need a lot of energy to kind of
operate these systems and so they tend
to be higher costs compared to capturing
from you know from a power plant or from
industrial process so it is expensive it
is going to be that technology you kind
of use to kind of mop up anything that
you can't capture so you don't want to
rely on this technology as you said it
is high cost and so it's kind of the
last result dr
thanks very much indeed
thank you stay with us coming up after
the break i'm going to be joined by the
economist vicky price and the
independence climate columnist donica
mccarthy they're standing by ready and
waiting and uh they'll be telling us
what they think about the future of
fossil fuels and is electric really the
future for our cars that's coming up
next
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
and now it's coming from both sides
and it's moving this way
clearly not had very much to eat at all
a lot of them extremely thin and very
frail
the people here are praying quietly to
themselves
i'm alex crawford and i'm skye's special
correspondent based in istanbul
now they're trying to finish the job off
so they can move into the square
[Music]
okay it's okay no worries okay
they're becoming very sensitive
having the media around
they have no protective masks or
protective equipment at all
we aim to be the best and the most
trusted place in news
every time they touch them they spray
sprayed spray
this is the cocktail of drugs which the
doctors at this hospital have been
giving their coronavirus patients
made for people who want clarity in an
uncertain world
to the vineyards
i can't
imagine how much plastic is lying at the
bottom of this huge lake
it's estimated that around 70 of our
coastlines are experiencing increased
erosion
[Music]
we start with a steel structure that we
put into the sea floor we then pass a
very small electrical current between
what we call an anode and the cathode
the structure itself is the cabinet
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
did you know if you use less energy we
can reduce air pollution
like turning off the lights yep
it'll be a gray and foggy start to
friday with patchy rain in the north and
west as skies brighten scattered showers
will break out these could turn heavy
and thundery again the focus for the
heavier downpours will be in the north
and east
taking a look at the daily air quality
index where levels of air pollution are
banded from one being low to 10 being
very high low levels of air pollution
are expected on friday with just the odd
pocket of moderate air pollution in the
north
the air quality report sponsored by
phillips air purifiers
hello and welcome back to the daily
climate show on sky news now we're
getting straight to discussing the
climate issues of the day now and
challenging the solutions to them as
well with economist and former joint
head of the uk's government economic
service vicki price and the independence
climate columnist donica mccarthy so a
very good evening to both of you good to
see you both
so earlier in the show we heard how
there needs to be a huge drop in the
production of oil and gas over the next
10 years if the world's going to avoid
the worst effects of global warming the
think tank carbon tracker says that
reducing fossil fuel investment will be
key to tackling the climate crisis
but with big oil companies still being
funded to drill for oil how can this
change happen so dunker first of all at
the uk's big oil companies say they've
got a plan they say they're going to get
to net zero by 2050. so should they be
persuaded to
cut their fossil fuel production more
quickly and if so how do you go about it
well the first thing is the
international energy agency report this
year stated that we we could not afford
to invest any new investments in new
fossil fuels if we are to reach net zero
2050 so the very first step we need to
take is to end investments in new fossil
fuels and that can be done in two ways
the government needs to regulate it and
secondly the banks need to stop lending
billions of dollars to the all
corporations to expand their current
exploration and and projects
then we need them we need to look at how
we phase out over the next 10 to 15
years the remaining production
okay and let's take a look at why we're
talking about this vicky because here
this is what the carbon tracker has said
about fossil fuel investment they say 13
billion pounds of fossil fuel investment
approved in 2020 was inconsistent with
global warming of 1.65 degrees not to
mention the 1.5 degree target so do you
think the government should step in to
stop investment in fossil fuel companies
right now
i think there is no doubt that something
needs to happen if we are to meet the
targets but it's worth bearing in mind
that
in fact if you look at the energy
companies the independent energy
companies which are funded by central
banks uh sorry by the banking system
which the central banks of course
control and therefore can do something
about it they only i think
account for something like
15 percent of um production some 12
percent of oil and gas reserves so quite
a lot of the rest is held by national
uh oil companies uh
run by states so countries basically own
them
and they are subjects actually to very
different rules so we got to watch what
we do in terms of how we uh address it
by just attacking if you like
western energy companies that for the
moment anyway provide quite a lot of
what we need certainly in the west
although we've seen periods of course
with oil crisis when we have been
relying quite a lot on uh other parts of
the world to provide us with oil which
have of course led to very substantial
increases in prices and drops in in gdp
and so on in the western world
recessions and and so on so we have to
be a little bit careful
about wishing to if you like
uh attack firms which at present
provided with quite a lot of our needs
and second what they do is okay
i'm going to let donald come in there
quickly
yeah it's not a question of attacking
these companies these corporations what
carbon tracker is saying clearly
investing billions and trillions of
dollars in new fossil fuel investments
is actually endangering those companies
future
many some some old companies have
already moved out of oil and gas to
renewables such as orested and what
they're saying is that if if if bp and
shell invest trillions of dollars
including the state corporations around
the world they're investing in in in
products that cannot be sold and that's
a disaster for the future economy and
you're right
the international energy agency report
didn't refer just to western oil
corporations but to all oil corporations
whether state or private so it's clear
absolutely clear from an economic point
of view
investing in new fossil fuels is
actually putting a suicide note to the
future of our economy and we cannot
afford it and i would say to people
today they really need to look at where
their bank accounts are and to ensure
that they switch them away from banks
are investing in in destruction of our
future okay i'm going to move us on
vicky if that's okay to our next subject
because it's world ev day electric
vehicle day designed to celebrate the
benefits of more sustainable cars but
are electric vehicles really the answer
to how we'll all need to get around in
the future once petrol and diesel cars
are phased out vicky what do you think
of this are electric cars the future in
your view
i think they are the future but of
course for the moment they are still
quite costly to produce they emit quite
a lot of uh you know co2 in the
production of them
and uh they are very expensive for most
people uh and of course they rely on
batteries which need to improve very
significantly i think it is worth
bearing in mind that there are loads of
um
technologies of the future that we're
going to be depending on and battery is
going to be one of them um if they're
sorted out properly in terms of the
range that they allow you to have
and also in terms of the cost of
producing them and whatever you do with
you know once they run out of their
lifetime themselves uh in fact disposing
of them then uh of course tvs are a way
of getting around in the future and i
think definitely the investment needs to
go there but we're not there yet okay
and let's take a look at a few stats
donakur because um we can see that in
august 2021 so last month it's that we
saw a
32.2 increase in pure electric car sales
in the uk that compares to the same
month the year before so consumer demand
clearly on the up but do you think they
solve our green transport issues
um electric vehicles are
an excellent response for emergency
vehicles and essential vehicles but
there are 1.4 billion vehicles on the
planet
let's take an average of 10 tons of
carbon to to create one of those
then you're talking about something like
14 billion tons of carbon emitted to
switch our fleet over that's 3.5 percent
of our remaining carbon budget
for one car somebody buys a new ev or a
new diesel car this year you're talking
between 10 to 30 years of the
electricity missions for their household
so you're basically saying you shouldn't
drive at all we should give up
all cars including electric ones
well something like 70 of trips in the
uk are under two miles
we actually need to switch to public
transport and walking and cycling for
this for those journeys okay if
these are fine for emergency vehicles
but we can't we and the positive thing
about us if we do that we get cleaner
cities we get safer streets and our kids
can be playing in in neighborhoods again
vicki price do you think that's right
that our main focus really needs to be
on public transport and if absolutely
possible we should give up our cars
well the investment that needs to go
into public transport improvements is
huge and we're not going to get that
done and it's not just us of course here
in the uk i mean look what's going on
elsewhere look at the us for example
where cars are absolutely essential the
public transport
system doesn't work look at the
developing countries too one way of
getting around that is through electric
vehicles of course the the lifetime
savings that you make in terms of energy
are very significant and of course you
don't pollute the environment the way
that
cars are present do so uh yes i don't
think that uh you know moving out of
driving completely is the answer uh in
my view and i think evs uh give you a
very very substantial way of achieving
the climate change goals you need also
major looting problems um
so sorry we're out of time but i'll
leave you shaking your head there thank
you and vicky both very much indeed
and that's everything from us for today
join me on the show tomorrow will be the
director of cambridge zero and climate
scientist emmy shakbra and chief
executive of the fully charged show dan
caesar
do stay tuned coming up next it's sky
news tonight where we'll have the latest
from doha where the first commercial
flight to leave kabul airport has landed
stay with us
[Music]